[Music]
okay
so this is my review of your honor
episode
nine this is the penultimate episode of
the season
now first thing i want to bring up is
actually i would love some help from you
guys if someone can comment below
exactly what the time code is and what
episode this scene that we see in the
previously on here
of nancy castell looking at the pictures
that robin took that show she was with
the desire gang
and telling the grandma this i do not
remember ever seeing this scene please
correct me from wrong i
i just don't have recollection of it was
it a post-credits scene like the mcu
does
what is going on here i do not remember
this happening but please
let me know in the comments where the
scene came from so what reveals itself
in this episode and that's very
frustrating is that knowing this is a
penultimate episode
you really want the show to start giving
you a lot of payoffs for the overarching
story here the main
plot what's frustrating is this episode
actually feels more like an episode
five or six in a series because it
really in its own way
is mostly on a side story and wrapping
up
joey's story which i was frustrated with
earlier on them giving him so much
significance
played by chet hanks tom hanks's son he
does a really good job
no discredit to the actor but my
annoyance is that
we were really centered on joey a couple
episodes ago with taking those drugs
because it was
made so they can have something to fill
the time later on in an episode and
that's this episode with
just a new obstacle for michael to face
that obstacle being
joey now about to snitch on everything
and what the rinse wash and repeat
formula that's getting really dull and
repetitive in the show is that
michael faces an obstacle jimmy is
pissed about it and threatens michael
and michael now is on the clock
to figure it out and he ends up doing
something bad
and that happens again in this episode
why it's frustrating here is because
it is episode nine so now we really want
to get past the side stories we already
know
what happens in these situations because
we've already seen it a couple times
with michael
and let's start getting some serious
payoffs where we did get payoffs
and things kind of wrapping themselves
up on side stories
is also frustrating how they presented
it because it was a lot of just
characters transferring information to
another character that they didn't know
and it's not revealed in really clever
ways this is shown when nancy
is the one who breaks the news michael
has a son named adam which happens to be
the same name
of his daughter's boyfriend and he
connects the dots they see the facebook
page
but what's so unbelievable about this is
that a mob
boss like jimmy baxter wouldn't look
into
all of michael's relatives and someone
he's keeping on a leash
and now he's just like shocked that he
has a son and this
happens to be adam and we still don't
know what happened with the dna that was
supposed to reveal
on this inhaler they found never got the
test results back so frustrating but
it's such a lame
way for him to even figure out anyway
was just nancy kind of saying it
casually and that goes too with charlie
and his scenes with franny because
frannie's the one who reveals to him
that she knows
adam killed the baxter boy and this will
give the information to charlie to now
know but again it's just one character
transferring
the information to another it's not
really revealed in a really clever
interesting way
and a lot of people mostly were excited
about the mystery of what really
happened with the mother
well it's a really deflating reveal that
basically she was just having an affair
with someone in this desire gang and
that someone in this gang
killed her and michael knew about this
but somehow this didn't come up
in any scenes where he was around the
desire gang it wasn't talked about so
this felt almost like just out of left
field
and now adam doesn't know but they're
predictably setting up that the
grandma's gonna tell him
next episode and he's gonna flip out but
again it's not something really clever
here it's not like a wow
moment and i'm gonna say a really
unpopular opinion here but i'm i'm
feeling it when i watch it but i'm not a
fan of michael stuhlbarg's performance
in this i think he's over acting
it's so theatrical and why i'm saying
overacting is because
he is doing so much with his face that
it's actually distracting me
in each scene he's in where i am
watching an actor i know
acting is happening because it's so
bombastic that it's taking me
out and i'm actually getting really
annoyed by it again this is a very
praised actor in his career
rightfully so but this performance in
particular for me is just way
over the top now i will give props to
the writers here i i touched to the line
they threw in where
michael says when he's going to keep
joey just him in the room he says no no
no let's
let's keep our social distancing
everybody that was great i'm gonna give
him props because it's
a lot of shows have been struggling to
write good pandemic related writing but
that was that was clever i like that but
there's a lot of silly stuff here too
like what was really the point of joey
breaking his ankle do we have to see
this gross ankle
with really no point to it i mean he
didn't die from this ankle he
just was drugged by michael i'm happy we
got to see franny be the voice of the
audience here
telling adam how crazy he is to be
in love with fia baxter the sister of
the boy he killed
but there was really poor editing in
this scene i don't know why but in an
important moment for franny and adam
they just kept the camera on adam you
know
you gotta hit the beats here and where
we have to see franny's face too
adam's not doing anything with his face
and we're just watching it
and then we get this ridiculous scene
where they bring a priest to see phia
now they know
she's dating adam and you know i'll give
gina props though i don't give the
priest props that they're hinting at
that
adam's just a bad influence that he
could be work of the devil here they're
not wrong adam is the devil in the show
and he's
a colossally bad character but my
favorite scene in this episode is with
adam and charlie now
because charlie's reactions are gold
when adam's like yeah you know i'm
dating two girls one of them is a
teacher and then charlie's just like
oh whoa but you see charlie when he's
telling franny
to back off which again the scene and
story would be so much more effective if
this actress was an older actress it's
so frustrating that she looks so young
it doesn't work
but you see that he's threatening her
that he'll get her on charges
obviously for being with someone under
age but she mentions she knows what adam
did
and that again is a reveal to charlie
but it's also blackmail back in a sense
that
now they both have information they can
kind of use against each other but we'll
see
as we figured would happen that again
lee and nancy are just
getting more and more on to everybody in
this show
lee's now figuring out about the dirty
cop here she also doesn't know how to
pronounce
the name rocco she calls him rocco and
it's setting up now eugene kind of to be
the flip because she this whole show has
been telling eugene he's better than
this gang
he's actually a good kid and then you
know that's coming he's gonna
do something good next episode i also
love how they set some of these scenes
up like
i love that fia is just laying on the
couch reading and her father
jimmy is just sitting there watching her
read it's so strange
but the scene we've all been waiting for
and i'm so excited for to see next week
is jimmy wants to see adam and he wants
to see him now
if he is excited about this of course
she texts adam adam has no worry in the
world
even though his dad has warned him about
jimmy baxter and how dangerous this man
is
and he's actually excited to see this
guy like
it is the peak of hateable
adam here i was just like this is going
to go down in history it's one of the
worst
most unlikable characters we've ever
watched in a show and why i said that's
a problem with the show like this having
a character like adam being so unlikable
is like breaking bad when you start
disliking your protagonist which
was walter white there and here it's
michael you need someone
that you start to like more and that was
jesse and breaking bad and
here it's not adam he's actually more
unlikable than michael so you're just
again not finding someone to root for
here maybe the only likable character in
this show is eugene
but why i'm excited is i feel like the
only satisfying payoff we can really get
in the show at this point
is in the finale to see like adam be fed
to dogs by jimmy i would be so happy or
just thrown off a balcony
anything but i will say this episode was
decent
for how bad the last episode was
and you know i'd give it a 7.1 it was
okay it wasn't
horrible but you're gonna have a
disappointing feeling watching it
because it is episode nine here we've
gone this far
and you're not getting these big moments
you're not getting the full story
starting to get resolved here
having this whole joey story it's just
another side story you can
replace it with any other obstacle
michael's had in the show and that
jimmy just threatens him and then
michael does something bad to resolve it
that's it you've seen it a bunch of
times already and again
you kind of can just see where this is
all going next episode they've given you
a lot of predictable
outcomes and like i said i'm frustrated
by how much information was just
transferred from one character to
another and not really the greatest
clever reveals for our characters to
learn
what we know as the audience let me know
down below what you thought this episode
though did you really like it did you
hate it do you think it was okay i'd
love to hear your thoughts i read every
comment and try to respond as many as i
can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss my review of your honors
finale next week and i also do one
division now and servant and i also do
celebrity interviews
and if you really like what i do here
please make sure to subscribe to my
monthly donation it's a paypal link down
below it's two dollars a month
it will give me the means necessary to
do this full time one day and give you
guys more videos
and content i would fully appreciate it
please follow me at steve barley show on
twitter and instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time